welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday we begin this half hour with a
generous contribution from a hollywood
star to a tiny startup charity in london
run by a pair of unlikely
philanthropists mts tayab has the story
[Music]
on an old phrase when life gives you
lemons
make lemonade at least that's what
little ayan musa and mikali shock have
been doing all summer long
squeezing lemon after lemon to raise
money for humanitarian aid
in yemen so what made you guys think hey
let's
make some lemonade and raise some money
for them it's because of me and they
want like lemonade
and i think i think everybody else in
the world like lemonade
yeah donuts again the six-year-old best
friends were inspired to set up their
stand
after watching an online news report
about yemeni children
in need did you feel sad when you saw
those pictures of those kids
yeah really suck we have loads of water
food medicine
and it's not fair they only have like
dirty water not that much stuff
and that's why we really wanted to help
them
no mickey take that one out please
darling and so with a lot of elbow
grease
and a little help from mom and dad they
started selling lemonade in the hopes of
raising five hundred dollars
but the customers kept coming and coming
thank you soon the boys collection box
was overflowing with cash
raking in thousands of dollars and
that's when they got their biggest
donation
[Applause]
from one of the world's biggest stars
angelina
jolie who not only made what ayan and
mikhail's parents are calling an
extremely generous contribution
she also sent the boys a note which
they've since framed
and aren't shy to share thank you for
what you and your friends are doing to
help
children in yemen i'm sorry i'm not
able to buy a lemonade from you
but i still like to make a donation
to your stand love angelia
jolie is the united nations special
envoy supporting displaced people
including in yemen since 2014
the country has been convulsed by a
brutal civil war between iranian-backed
houthi rebels
and a military coalition led by saudi
arabia
more than a hundred thousand people have
died millions have had to flee their
homes
and starvation is widespread
scale of the humanitarian crisis in
yemen may be hard for these two little
boys with such
big hearts to comprehend but ayan and
mikhail's parents say
it's not lost on their supporters thank
you
it's a community effort and it's friends
family everyone chipping in together i
already like cupcake
for these two besties even though summer
may be over
lemonade for everyone they have no plans
to stop selling lemonade
for yemen how much money do you want to
raise
100 trillion recipients this morning
saturday
infused east london
10 100 100 trillion it is a goal out of
a lot of cash money
and they're besties they finish each
other's thoughts i'm reading the the
jolene
stereo which is part about it